are you having trouble as a diversity or erg leader
to connect with your employees or members
well if you are listen up
since everybody lives in this virtual world of phone zoom email text everything like that
you need to do something different in order to increase the engagement of your members
of your employees or whatnot
you really need to go the extra mile
and within your erg
when there's a celebration coming up
a milestone a holiday
a cultural event
whatever it may be
send them something thoughtful
something that represents the culture
something nostalgic
sent a candle
whatever it may be
you probably know this better than I do
but there's always executive sponsors
there's always budget within companies to make sure employees feel valued
so don't be afraid to use that when needed
and if you ever need help
I can help you with all cultural gift giving
it's time to make things happen